[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi je suis un peu énervé parce
que j'ai pas dormi de la nuit quand vous
passez devant une commission comme ça et
qui vous exclut et que vous recevez un
mail en disant que vous êtes exclu mais
je lui dis mais c'est une blague ce mot
exclusion c'est quoi c'est comme quand
j'ai des sans-papiers des gens comme ça
vous connaissez mon engagement je me
suis battu toute ma vie et racisme et
autres quand je vois ça et ce mot exclu
bien sûr que j'ai pleuré hier les
investisseurs m'ont dit tu sais tes
croyants quand même on te connaît
Olivier chou qu'on le connaît on sait
très bien que on te met à l'épreuve oui
mais les épreuves ça peut tuer je suis
exténué je suis fatigué et je vais curé
qu'on me lâche comme ça clairement la
DNCG m'a dit monsieur se mesure j'étais
avec mon trésorier hier vous savez
écartez-vous des politiques je les dis à
Monsieur carloli ce matin qui m'a fait
venir j'ai dit Carl c'est peut-être une
cabale
tu défends aujourd'hui le neveu de
monsieur le Président Monsieur Macron
qui est venu à Poissy on connaît la
proximité de Monsieur carloli avec le
président ça n'a rien à voir peut-être
tu es dit maintenant tu dois m'aider
parce que j'ai rien fait moi j'ai
absolument rien fait je me suis dit
est-ce que c'est une chasse aux
sorcières monsieur car le livre qui m'a
fait venir il y a 6 ans m'appeler deux
fois ce matin j'arrivais au boulot très
tôt sur ma moto comme tous les matins je
suis artisan et je travaille comme un
fou ça c'est entre parenthèses parce que
le football c'est du bénévolat j'y mets
de l'argent et j'ai voilà on s'est
compris
la problématique c'est que
nous sommes passés l'adncg
au mois de mars fin mars et on leur
expliquait mon expert comptable et
moi-même et mon trésorier il y avait un
déficit de 150000 euros au 31 décembre
2022 on a depuis cette date là chercher
des partenaires aujourd'hui ce club je
dirige depuis 6 ans on nous avait
prévenu que c'était compliqué puisque
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a eu l'histoire et
vous le savez de ces licences
malheureusement qui nous ont coûté 7
points et 34000 euros il y a eu ce
joueur monsieur Clémenceau que j'avais
négocié à l'époque m'enlevant un joueur
qualité que j'avais été chercher un
grand joueur pour Chartres j'ai une
procédure contre charte 15000 euros ça
jamais été donné j'ai arrêté les
procédures parce que ça coûte plus cher
en
avocat que et j'obtiendrai jamais cette
somme en début d'année c'est-à-dire au
mois de septembre on m'a indiqué que
Veolia ne serait plus partenaire et
engie ils m'ont dit texto l'adncg et
j'ai des témoins président s vous avez
jusqu'au 10 juin très bien je leur ai
dit prenez soin de vous comme d'habitude
j'ai présenté des investisseurs j'ai
présenté beaucoup de gens depuis
quelques temps vous voyez des projets
sont là des très beaux projets refusés
on a un rendez-vous demain pour
évidemment quelque part on va faire on
va faire appel pour l'honneur du club
pour le mien pour montrer Aurier pour la
ville même je reçois des messages de
Jean-Marc puit d'Angers de mes amis du
PSG etc
on connaît ma probité tous les gens me
disent Olivier c'est pour rien tu as
rien fait aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
d'être abandonné j'en ai après personne
mais j'ai la rage
[Applaudissements]